is
welcome uh i've i have uh i start with
the survey please a lot of people here
how many people are graduates of
hillsdale college
how many people have had a class with
steve smith
and so i happen to know that there's
probably 300 people
who've had a class with steve smith in
the city and most of them have stayed
away
well done steve okay
so a lot of you are most of you are not
graduates of hillsdale college
and uh thanks for being here i'm larry
arn
i work at the college this is the allen
p
kirby junior center for constitutional
studies and citizenship
it's a oh look the waylands are here
sorry i keep seeing old friends and i
can't help myself
by the way the great linda chavez is
here tonight she should stand up
she's a tough and wonderful and
principled woman and an old friend of
mine i can't help but recognize her
this center is an odd thing there isn't
anything else like it in this city
because it's a teaching place with an
affinity
for the principles of the country and
that's because the college was founded
that way in 1844
it was founded to support civil and
religious freedom and intelligent piety
those are sacred causes at our college
and we
we teach them we serve them in the way
that teaching institutions do we study
and we think and we learn and we try to
prove things
we try to dwell in the high and
beautiful things
and the college has done very great
service for our country a lot of it's
commemorated in this building
it's a fact that some of our students
helped carry the casket of abraham
lincoln to his final resting place
and they had earned the right to do that
by winning the congressional medal of
honor in battle
we're proud of things like that at our
college and it's a story about our
college that our service to our country
always grows more intense when it's
dangerous
it's when a crisis is upon us that
fundamental things come open and right
now is just such a crisis
and colleges are good at fundamental
things most many of these people in this
room
i know from the time they were 18 years
old i had them in class many of them
myself
i know what they're like i look at them
almost like children of my own
i've watched them grow up and now i
marvel that they've become so
accomplished i can hardly believe it
and because we deal with people of that
age we are trapped
we can never get on beyond the first and
the most important things we never
really get to do anything very
sophisticated
we always just get to do things that are
very high
and things that are very high and very
fundamental
those are the things all of a sudden
that people become very
interested in when everything is at
stake
shall we live in the united states of
america
under a system of constitutional rule
which requires limited government and
separation of powers
and representation or shall what is
soon to happen if it's not stopped
happen and that is
the public sector actually grow to be
larger than the private sector in its
expenses
and if that happens is that not a
fundamental change in the whole meaning
and purpose of the country
and such a change could only be
justified
by a different interpretation of men and
things and god and nature
and so if you if you're interested in
that kind of subject today you have to
study
men and things and god and nature and
guess what we do for a living
and so our idea about this building is
we built this building so that the
activity of studying those things could
go on right here in the city
where it doesn't go on and where then
the city could learn by its
proximity to that activity that
everything is a tool
some things are things for which all
tools are to be used
and we think that attitude would be very
good for this city
and so we built this pretty building and
we welcome a lot of people like you we
welcome our own students and then we
welcome people in active politics and
talk more slowly when they're here
sorry that was an easy joke many of them
are very bright and
if it's an intense time then it's time
to study
statesmanship because the people who are
the greatest statesmen
are the people who can lead through a
time when everything is up for grabs
what better example of that is there
than sir thomas moore saint thomas more
because what did he do if prudence is
the virtue of the statesman and it's a
kind of understanding
if it finds the truth and the high
things and the details and circumstances
that swell around
if it has the capacity to master those
details and not let's
lose sight of the final ends then
whoever waged a war of wits for his own
life and the soul of his country
more famously or on such a high level as
thomas more
and because it happened on such a high
level it is a lifelong task to get any
real grasp of what was going on there
because he was a man of incredible power
and sophistication
and none of us mere mortals can really
hope ever to approach that kind of
understanding
unless someone comes along to help us
and that someone would have to be a
teacher
and it just so happens there is a great
teacher
of thomas moore here tonight
to be a teacher at hillsdale college is
a challenging calling
because those of you who've been there
will know the truth of what i'm about to
say
if you're not a good teacher you get
hazed out of the place because people
won't take your classes
and we do the radical thing at the
college that we don't really set
lower limits on classes and so if you
walk down the hall and you see somebody
sitting and then there's only one other
person in the room
it means that professor smith is not
teaching that class
he thrives in an atmosphere
he uh so what did
i i can never remember where he went to
college did you go to notre dame and
then ud
yeah and and see the notre dame thing
he's a late bloomer he couldn't get into
hillsdale
you know you wouldn't predict based on
that experience that he would be the man
i'm about to show you
he uh he did study there at the
university of dallas in graduate school
with a man named wegmer whom i happen to
know a little bit
and he's a fantastic man and one of the
great knowers
of thomas moore steve smith is
uh he's a good you know to me what he is
is a great colleague who's always
delightful to meet on the sidewalk
because you never fail to learn
something when you do he's always got
something great to say
he sends you little quotes from the bard
as he puts it
or dante or more the three things he
probably loves the best and certainly
blows off about the most
and he and he carries them around in his
mind
and uh if you ever go and sit in one of
his classes
it's a fantastic experience and he knows
those three things he's got
books out about more that so far are
ones a source book just recently
published a book of more letters called
for all seasons
and they are fundamental to the
scholarship on moore because there are
ways to find out the facts about him and
there's some interpretation in there
that
steve has written on the basis of his
deep knowledge he's got a book coming
out soon
that i'm waiting for very keenly about
shakespeare's late plays
and it's going to be fabulous because i
know because he sent me little notes
about things he's thinking about and
it's probably half the book by now
i get i imagine i'll still be expected
to pay for the flipping book
and i will
of steve it's clear that in a great
faculty
he's one of the few best and that's
because his life is a meditation
upon that combination of thought and
action that makes up human life
and for that reason he follows in the
footsteps of thomas more
and is the best equipped man i know to
help us do the same thing
please welcome stephen smith
there's some water here well you notice
dr aaron did not mention
how many of his former students are in
attendance uh
we could take up that during the
reception afterwards um
thanks of course to the kirby center and
to david bob
and to the fusco foundation for the
invitation
very happy to be here and thank you to
to you all
for sharing this night with me and a
little bit of time on
sir thomas more i must say i'm surprised
to see so many
friendly faces former students and
current students
here it warms my heart and uh and stirs
a lot of good good memories from
from hillsdale i should also add before
i launch into the talk here
i've arrived in dc with my dear wife
laura
and our three sons who are being watched
by my niece right
now if you hear sirens um
talk to laura but any event if you
really
if you don't think washington dc is a
great city
you should really come and visit it with
an eight-year-old a 10 year old and a 12
year old
because they think this is the greatest
city they've ever been in
and i know that for some of us it can
strike us differently
but it's been very beautiful to see
their their excitement over over this
city and over this place
so sir thomas moore a man in full and a
man for our season
thomas more has intrigued generations of
writers and thinkers
citizens and statesmen alike and i
wanted to just start by invoking
um the words of some of his admirers
because
you know you can know a man by his
admirers often
william shakespeare wrote of moore as
quote marrying wit
and wisdom which i'll talk a little bit
more about later
and living justice for truth's sake and
his conscience
one thing a lot of people don't know is
that shakespeare collaborated
on a play that was never produced called
the book of sir thomas moore
and that play contains pages in
shakespeare's own hands the only
surviving
writing we have from william shakespeare
speeches
from and by about thomas more a
mysterious text when it was never
produced
it may be because it was you know the
attempted
you know his first production of it was
during elizabeth's reign but any case
very positive play about moore
remarkably so
in a very intriguing piece of writing
jonathan swift
the author of gulliver's travels
numbered thomas more among the six great
defenders of liberty in the western
tradition
and even went so far as to claim more
was the quote
person of greatest virtue these islands
ever produced
now if you've read gulliver's travels
you know you have a sort of world-class
misanthrope on your hands
uh and jonathan swift as elizabeth
bennett said of mr darcy
you have a propensity to hate everybody
uh and so when i read this for the first
time i was stunned
the person of the greatest virtue of
these islands has have ever produced
you gotta be kidding me jonathan swift
and of course in our own are
not our own but the 20th century i was
born in 1972 sorry
not that young winston churchill sir
winston churchill
admired the noble and heroic stand of
moore
and chesterton wrote that moore quote
may come to be counted the greatest
englishman
or at least the greatest historical
character in english history
chesterton also wrote in the 1920s that
moore was
yes important at that turning point in
the west
history of the west but he would be
truly important
in about 100 years time which would put
that round about
2020 or so what would have moved
chesterton to make such a statement
that we would need the example of thomas
moore
in about a hundred years time about
2020.
perhaps he was a little off i mean by a
decade or so
but in any case that time is nearly upon
us and so i offer these
comments partly in response to that
question right
and this one too how did one free and
educated man
make an impact like this on his own
country and across centuries
such that he would be canonized on the
eve of world war ii
named lawyer of the millennium in 1999
that's a tough poll to win
and finally proclaimed patron of
statesmen
at the beginning of the third millennium
most importantly though
what councils does such a man offer to
all of us to all of you
you're obviously ambitious and good
willed
many of you are at work in this place or
want to work in this place
fit by nature perhaps called to be
statesmen yourselves
to play a decisive role in the daily
drama of your country your community
your family
sometimes a hidden role sometimes a very
public one
the focus of these brief remarks is on
becoming
a statesman the focus is not
so much on policy uh and the stuff of
czars not so much about the ever-present
business as blink
blinking at us notifying us through our
smartphones
but rather the stuff of the interior
the stuff of character our stuff within
what homer called the homer was the only
poet more
praised without any qualification
whatsoever
the pith of the person the pith of the
man
it's forging its direction its truth its
consequences
and its decisive importance
now very briefly as you heard from dr
arne moore was a londoner
an englishman born in 1478 died in 1535
among the best educated englishmen
educated at oxford
then he followed his father's uh and his
family's tradition
legal civil service uh in london
he was a member of parliament from as
early as 1504
he worked for 30 years
in governing under sheriff of london
diplomat he entered the king's service
in 1518.
by the way he wasn't crazy about
entering the king's service
this is a dispute among the scholars one
reason being that he'd give up
his status as a citizen of london and
become the king's man
he thought becoming the king's man was a
risky proposition
and we might think ahead to 1535. and
probably chuckle with him because he had
a great sense of humor
entering the king's service speaker of
the house
chancellor of the duchy of lancaster
lord chancellor of england
dead on a scaffold in 1535.
i remember about 14 years ago i had the
privilege of standing in
the tower of london in his cell which is
very hard to
get into and i stood there a very silent
and quiet place not particularly
accommodating
not exactly the hampton inn and i really
thought for the first time in my life
really struck by the question
how was it possible to play a part like
this man play
to sit in this cell at the end at the
end of a tremendous life of drama for 14
months and then to be
unjustly condemned and have your head
forcibly removed from your body which by
the way was mercy from henry
a lot of people don't know that if you
were friends with the king beheading
if not i suppose drawing and quartering
um
you might say with friends like that
it was mercy right um but how is it
possible to play a part like moore
played
with myself basic fundamental wonder
right
now one thing we'll we'll do tonight one
thing i want to call attention to is the
need not to skip over
moore's life and jump into the tower of
london's cell
because that is not how he lived not
what he did
occasionally you'll hear folks say
you know persecutions are great we
should welcome them
yeehaw this was not moore's
approach in fact he exercised every
means
possible to avoid this
to the tune of writing one million
words working constantly
he remarked in the tower of london i
think the work
hurt my heart it cost me my health it's
in the months before his death
but i would do it again i was trying to
get some
some sense of a million words just just
for fun you know
kind of thing you do when you're just
writing a speech all by yourself
um that's 35
000 tweets
or perhaps something more substantial
1400
op-eds
tireless right so
i was thinking that you know how is it
possible to play a part like that
and then let's not skip over the middle
so quickly
moore was a statesman for many years
before this
no less than 30 before
those fateful days at the end of his
life
for the talk tonight i've gleaned 10
councils from
my study of more from the last decade or
so
these councils are offered to you free
of charge
for all seasons for the seasons before
the prison cell
and if it comes to it for the prison
cell as well
you will discover i hope that moore's
world
is a good deal like our own a world of
family
community learning politics power
tragedy but a world in which he was
immersed
with care and love
a world that differs little from our own
now the man himself the knight
that's another matter a man in full
a man for our season thomas moore
challenges us and counsels us and
prepares us
for the seasons to come i think it's
important when you study
to let the book or what the person
challenge you
you have so many habits of reading at
arm's length
or not letting works of art
councils biography history
challenge us but of course this is how
more lived and
i want to invite you to to be challenged
of course we're all works in progress
but any event now to the councils
council one i'm trying to think of some
way to capture this
improve thy wit exclamation point he
wanted to use an exclamation point
it's high time we pause and take our own
education
and personal formation much much more
seriously
for more the most educated englishman of
his time
the only true genius in england liberal
education had as its purpose
the freedom of the person it was a path
to greatness of soul
in the words of seneca you see why
liberal studies are so called because
they are studies worthy of the free
but there is only one really liberal
study that which gives a person his
liberty
that is the study of wisdom that is
lofty that is brave
that is great sold the chancellor of
both oxford and cambridge moore was
convinced that he stood personally in
great need
regardless of his future profession
vocation
of just such an education in particular
he needed the philosopher's
understanding of human nature
the historian's knowledge and
understanding of his own country
the theologians teaching on eternity and
the soul
the poet's art of seeing and making and
moving human hearts
while there's much to say about moore's
understanding of each of these things i
want to focus on one in particular
in one of his later works more is having
a conversation it's a dialogue
with a young man fresh from cambridge a
sharp fellow but half educated
and doubtful of the importance of
liberal education in particular
as moore discusses the vital importance
of liberal education he observes
your reason dear sir is by study labor
and exercise
of the liberal arts strengthened and
quickened
and your judgment both in them and in
orators laws and stories much ripened
and although poets are taken by many men
just for
painted words or sofas yet they do much
help the judgment
and make a man among other things well
furnished in one special thing
without which all learning is in vain or
half-lame
what's that the young man asks a good
mother wit i love that expression well
good mother wit
gained in particular from the study of
the great poets
as one fruit of his own incomparable
education moore believed that
poetry especially the great poets
ripened this mother wit
this guardian wit this well-seasoned and
exercised practical judgment
a wit that helps the person day in and
day out
making him capable of good and
discerning service
the study of great poets in particular
delights the reader
by its beauty and moreover confers a
sense of the realities of the human
drama
an accurate perception of the nature of
things
especially exercises the wit the
imagination the intellect the desire
as moore writes elsewhere great poetry
works to instill the good through
sweetness and beauty
to foster the love of truth and wisdom
now perhaps in the reception afterwards
or in the q a
discuss his most famous book utopia
which is just such a book and just such
a
educational experience later moore
himself will be described as marrying
wit
and wisdom if we consider wit as poetry
and wisdom as philosophy
we can see that for thomas more wit
needs wisdom and wisdom needs wit
there needs to be a new marriage of
poetry and philosophy
after the great divorce of recent
centuries
the philosophers should not banish the
poets
nor should the poets mock the
philosophers
the two should like the blind man and
the lame man moore wrote about in one of
his poems
form a firm league of friendship and
concord
for the sake of their common good
perhaps in the midst of such pressing
concerns it can seem the height
of foolishness to say we must become
wittier
to foster mother wit we must study homer
and dante and shakespeare
but there it is we may have wisdom
but we seem to lack a little wit
robert bolt the great 20th century
playwright wrote a man for all seasons
god made the angel had this is thomas
more speaking
god made the angels to show his splendor
he made animals for innocence
plants for simplicity but men and women
he made to serve him wittily
in the tangle of their minds i should
add an important point
from thomas moore's biography he not
only studied these things
during his formal education this is
perhaps the most impressive thing about
him
but for 17 years
after he left oxford university
17 years cicero
latin classics greek classics rising at
four in the morning
mastering greek in three years such that
he could have a translation contest with
erasmus
into latin right
he was at once immersed in the detailed
business of london and governance
and yet he forged that zone of silence
that habit of reflection that habit of
study
such that a later writer would describe
his study as quote the watch and ward
of england the defense of england
was his study against a man is immersed
in practical affairs to an unprecedented
extent
and yet and yet and yet the habit of
reflection
the zone of silence his keen study
during all these years
devoted to smaller duties ordinary
offices and work
furnished him with the principles that
guided him and gave his political and
personal life
coherence unity and effectiveness
council one now council two
is based on cicero examine your favorite
image examine your own images
especially of a greatly lived and
greatly led human life
moore was known as the english christian
cicero which is very interesting title
to think about
english local his native place
cicero classical
christian biblical all three together in
a unity
in cicero's great work on the orator he
says the liberal arts were devised for
the purpose of fashioning the young
according to humanity and virtue
in his last work on duties cicero
counsels his son
this is the important point work out
your own ideas
sift your thoughts look within
to see what conception of a good person
the great soul you have within you
what image do you have in you of a
greatly led and greatly lived human life
it will be of decisive importance
aristotle said after all man is the most
imitative of all creatures
so that image that we favor whatever it
is
what is it have we examined ourselves on
that point
decisively important he adds a serious
caution to this
if you don't do this you may end up
another caesar
who overturned all laws human and divine
to achieve for himself a principal
fashioned according to his own erroneous
opinion and image
on the one hand he greatly lived and
greatly led life a free life
on the other hand a tyrannical life
self-destructive violent um
and ending badly the prince of denmark
then i
couldn't get too far without a reference
to shakespeare was right to ask
what is a man what is a greatly lived
human life
whatever answer we make to this question
really will be the idea
the image according to which we fashion
ourselves
let's examine ourselves on this point
what do we admire as a moving image of
greatness
what do we have in the treasure house of
our memory are the images good
are they ambiguous are they awful have
we ever examined them or tested them
what's the best image of human greatness
available to us
for more it was the union as shakespeare
wrote in macbeth
of highness and holiness
council three pursue integrity
but don't be surprised by frailty
moore was the first english writer to
use the word integrity
he understood integrity to be
consistency in thought word and action
a demanding but liberating form of life
requiring sure conscience and sure
deliberation
to achieve its end
consistency in thought in word indeed
oneness
of soul to be blunt
moore's last year is the time in the
tower really the fruit of a lifelong
habitual daily struggle to be one man
instead of two or
three or whatever the case may be
here is an urgent point do i struggle to
live this
oneness am i a truthful person
are my heart and my face one are my
thought and my words
one am i consistent is my life a unity
or a duplicity
am i one person or perhaps some strange
equation of imaginary numbers
that don't quite add up
the fact that moore was canonized should
not hide from our eyes
that his case was precisely as ours is
and hence the real value of his
struggles and examples he found it
difficult
to be one man instead of two
he found it a daily struggle to live
this kind of of unity now you know
if you cast your mind into to macbeth
shakespeare's great play
the anthem of the witches around the
cauldron
double double toil
and trouble you know for shakespeare
this is
as important a point as it is for more
double
trouble single
rare beautiful powerful
consistent free so pursued integrity
don't be surprised by frailty the
difference between thomas moore
who was able to live in this way and
others in his time
was habitual attention to his conscience
following its trustworthy counsel and
lead he did not make peace with his sins
or his errors
when he became aware of them he
confessed them and began again this
quest to be
one man because
of his understanding of the human being
he was not surprised by his own frailty
he just knew what to do about it
it's interesting if you look at his
writings on education his daughters were
the best educated women in europe if
you've seen man for all seasons you may
remember
the scene where henry speaks to margaret
meg in latin
and margaret responds and
henry is at a complete loss perhaps
because his own latin is not so good
whoa hey how did you happen
um well more took great care over his
children's education he knew education
was a profound
experience and part of what makes a
culture
great and sustains it i suppose that's
why we should pay special attention
not just to current debates on say
health care healthcare
but what of education right
but when he spoke to his children's
teacher he said teach them latin
teach them the classics teach them the
church fathers teach them scripture
teach them this to
give this long list as you might imagine
but he said never forget to teach them
to pay habitual attention
to their conscience to form the
conscience to give it
light so that it can help them
he wrote to his daughter's teacher the
whole fruit of their education
should consist in the testimony of god
and a good peaceful conscience
thus they will be inwardly at peace
neither stirred by excessive praise
and flattery nor pray to ridicule
and mockery pay attention
thomas more urges us to the conscience
daily and especially take the pains to
educate it form it
and help it do its work
of course on this point this council on
integrity
um everyone in moore's story
experienced a tremendous reversal of
fortune
the turn and in more and in shakespeare
question it's often asked is well when
it turns on you
these to these political men when you
who are ruling now
are brought low what will you have left
after your power is taken from you your
office is taken from you
your influence is taken and shakespeare
gives a beautiful answer to this in one
of his late plays
all that i have left is my robe
and my integrity to heaven and the soul
dies
happily actually counsel four
live order for the love of life yourself
your family and your friends
again this dude has a hammer on this
point by all accounts thomas moore was
extraordinarily busy
and he didn't even have an iphone
or even the crudest of notification
centers
my new favorite thing father friend
lawyer judge member of parliament
author thinker wretched singer even in
his local choir
moore's is a story of the struggle
to do all things well to be just
to each of his commitments to serve his
priorities with love
and to live his earthly vocation with
care that word vocation is particularly
important for
thomas more kong it's the subject of one
of his first books the life of pico
and pico for all of his intellectual
greatness
becomes a tragic figure because
he either did not ask what am i called
to do
or when he found out what he was called
to do he did not correspond to the call
so for mortis this concept of vocation
was tremendously important
he also laughed a bit about being so
busy have anyone read utopia
by the way we have to have a memo to a
radio commentary a commentator who
thinks the utopia is
something other than a satire i've
learned about this in recent days
thomas more was not a socialist right
despite the monument in red square
moscow
that is uh dedicated to him um we can
talk again about that later
but in in the preface to utopia he talks
about what his life was really like
he's like i'm just trying to publish
this thing just trying to finish this
book he's writing to his friend peter
giles
my other tasks peter they leave me no
leisure at
all i am constantly engaged in legal
business
i plead i hear i give an award as an
arbiter i decide a case as a judge
i pay a visit of courtesy to one man i
go on business to another
i devote almost my entire day in public
to other men's affairs
and only the remainder to my own i leave
to myself that is to learning and
writing almost nothing at all
when i have returned home i must talk
with my wife chat with the children
confer with my servants
all of this activity i count my proper
business
when it must be done and it must be done
unless you want to be a stranger in your
own home
amid these occupations the day the month
the year slips away when can i ever find
time to write
i've yet spoken a word about sleep or
eating
which for many people takes up as much
time as sleep
and sleep takes up almost half a man's
life
so i get for myself only the time i
felch
from sleeping and eating now of course
you want to add to this
he did publish utopia but he was able to
finish things and yet
immersed in this way throughout his
entire
working life adult life supposed to take
away value from that quotation though
which always has struck me
unless you want to be a stranger in your
own house
moore was very much aware of that
possibility
that temptation and he would
prove just to each of his commitments
if emerging one thing in this council or
even tonight
it's that this kind of attentive real
well-led
life is both desirable and possible
it's not just a fiction uh or a nice
dream
of course it's arduous it's difficult
but we know that which costs little is
valued
little that's council
council five um we're a brass tax
council
i'll never forget it's once asked by a
friend
dude have you thought about brass tax
right he was rebuking my my wayward
idealistic temperament that was flying
around
and not attending to things council five
know your profession
has it ever struck you i need more
knowledge and capability
than i have at present one of my
favorite things in all of england
is the great vine at hampton court
palace has anyone seen this
it was the master work of capability
brown
this famous gardener look what a title
capability brown
um but
do i need more knowledge and capability
is good will
good desires even good opinions enough
again moore's example is instructive
nothing can replace the careful study of
particulars
in real experience what you might call
the doctoral program
of painful but instructive living there
may be the appearance of knowledge
without such things but not a wisdom
that can govern
nothing can ever replace moore's example
suggests
knowing what you are defending affirming
it as clearly and deeply and precisely
as possible
again if we focus too much on the death
of moore which is truly splendid
a great glimmering in the gloom even we
might pass over too
quickly this nitty gritty of his
professional
life his utter competency
and professional excellence under
sheriff master of the laws of england
lawyer judge
edwardson figured 900 cases
he could dispatch i mean it's incredible
to consider
you have to know something to be able to
judge like that so quickly
and so fairly
he even worked one of his first jobs on
the sewer system of
london and this is to me is one of these
examples that actually tells you
something about thomas more
that yeah got to fix it
oh it's causing a lot of trouble right
immersed
even in that right he was a fully formed
citizen who knew exactly what made his
native london great
and whose understanding of justice and
prudence was
formed through the daily struggles of a
free and virtuous and self-governing
place
it also of course helped that he had
studied the history of his own country
the way tacitus studied rome
council six and that this is the council
that
i gave a talk to house staffers
yesterday and it seemed to strike a cord
um i know it does for me as well so i
included it
be a friend never a flatterer
it's actually interesting anecdote
erasmus thomas more's great friend wrote
he was born for friendship
if you want a perfect example of the art
of friendship
study this man of course we're all born
for friendship
one of the interesting things
historically is that more and erasmus
both realize that people in positions of
power
authority find this to be a very elusive
experience not uncommon to hear someone
say
oh so and so he has no friends
though he's surrounded by people all day
long
meetings dinners monday tuesday
wednesday thursday friday saturday
sunday around the clock
but then the person who's see closest to
him
doesn't seem to have friends
on this point it's interesting [ __ ]
erasmus
gave a piece of writing from plutarch
to henry viii when he was young it's
called how to tell a flatterer from a
friend
it's a short piece of writing and even a
life-changing piece of writing
plutarch was one of shakespeare's great
teachers
he was the man who in the life of
alexander the great says you know
sometimes the smallest details of a
man's life
the way he makes a joke the way he
introduces some
these little things tell us more about
the truth of a man
than the greatest battles or the
bloodiest sieges so plutarch was
in one of shakespeare's master teachers
and in this essay how to tell a
flatterer from a friend
he tries to help alert the reader and
teach the reader
about the all too common experience of
being flattered
and the all too rare experience of true
friendship
so erasmus and moreth would be a great
idea to give this piece of writing to
henry
who was a young man with fabulous wealth
unlimited personal power and
you know a group of of men surrounding
him who are not
exactly looking out for his best
interest and so be a friend
never a flatter how do we understand
friendship aristotle said it's like two
bodies sharing one soul
scripture says if you found a friend you
found a treasure
and yet one contemporary writer has said
referring to america
we suffer from friendship deficit
disorder
especially men it's a rare
experience too rare it's like living a
riddle again being surrounded by people
being communication with people
constantly and yet without
friendship friends will the good for one
another we're told by the tradition
friends dare to help and correct one
another we're told by the tradition
perhaps the most graphic examples of
moore's friendship
friendship to his daughter by not coming
out of the cell though she begged him
or even his death what are thomas
moore's last words
i die the king's good servant and gods
first
who is he quoting on the scaffold well
he said it this was henry viii's counsel
to moore when moore entered his service
moore was concerned that serving the
king might
hurt him he said thomas
i want you to be to be one of my men
right and you will never you know you'll
always be able to live
god first and then the king so moore's
death those words that were quoted
i've always understood as something like
an last act of
friendship directed
by moore to henry viii
reminding him finally one of moore's
last letters that he wrote you can read
about this in the new book of letters
it was written to a man named anthony
bonavizi
and bon visi was an italian lifelong
friend of thomas moore
he visited more in the tower he risked
royal wrath in doing so
brought him a warm gown brought him some
wine brought him a little conversation
nothing spectacular and moore wrote just
a few
months before his death thank you
anthony
this was the experience that has helped
me in this place in this tower
it says through you through friendship
i've experienced something like
a certain taste of the loving kindness
of god
and you know he meant that he
loved french born for friendship
and especially now right
how are our friendships
and and can we do everything we can to
improve
the culture of of friendship right
and never to be flatterers council seven
and then another sort of brass but
important council
be a citizen of citizens
or to use more zone language be a first
citizen
be a leading citizen in his early
writings in particular
more advocated the education and the
formation of quote
first or leading citizens so this is
what a country needs
most this type of
soul first citizen or leading citizen my
mentor jerry wegemer
has explained this beautifully in his
new book the young thomas more
the renaissance the rebirth of education
and good
letters was accompanied by a deep
understanding of the need for well and
wisely trained citizens thomas moore's
words
which you'll hardly find anywhere he
says
if a people is ever to be free
self-governing
and virtuous like shakespeare moore
shared the concern
about the formation of such citizens and
the pain and the tragedy when they are
absent
it would be a tragedy both writers
suggest
for christians to be equipped with the
best principles
and yet incompetent in the exercise of
rule over themselves and others
should not slight human things human
virtues and human art
shakespearean tragedy in particular is
as
painful as any uh on this subject
and shakespeare seems to point out both
the
the the truth the goodness of of certain
characters
and yet their incompetence in the play
and the incompetence is is actually
deadly
in shakespearean drama for some reason
they don't know how
to be as active and effective as
possible they never learned that art
though they have the best principles in
the play
council eight aligned it more like quite
a bit
be wise as serpents and innocent as
doves
this point is on the importance of the
cardinal virtue of prudence
in that play book of sir thomas more
more plays the part of prudence than his
play within the play
and of course was the part he played in
english history
i might also add be wise as serpents and
innocent as doves
do everything you can do to avoid
another civil war
do everything you can to foster
friendship and concord here
this point on prudence is one of the
most important councils of more
do we understand this word
do we consciously seek to become more
and more truly prudent
and not simply cunning or astute or
clever
what is it the habitual power and
ability to see and make judgments and
decisions
in the light of what actually exists
without the distortions that arise from
our desires expectations or bad
imaginations
the proper act of this virtue according
to thomas aquinas
is command you are to command
if you were to lead yourself and others
you need this virtue in particular
as mentioned earlier moore did not rush
into the tower of london
he served practically with that wit and
that wisdom
exercising every means in service of the
end until it became no longer possible
to do so
all means were exercised to preserve his
liberty and to keep the country from
descending into chaos and civil war
so wise as serpents innocent
as doves prudence now the last two
councils are i suppose the tower
councils but they're very important
council nine famous line from utopia
never abandon the ship in a storm
because you cannot control the wind
this council of course is on the virtue
of fortitude
for many the virtue most obviously
associated with thomas more
is fortitude what is it what do we mean
when we use this word
we encourage guts do we mean toughness
like what do we mean
the habitual power of enduring hardship
even
death even wounds in the service of a
high and arduous good
again most graphically it is the
willingness to suffer wounds
to be hurt the willingness even to
endure death
one specific act of friendship that
moore encourages us
and i think is don't abandon the ship in
the storm
learn what fortitude is and practice
fortitude he needed it
he feared in the tower he feared for his
family he feared for his daughters
he knew the taste of fear as macbeth
said
and yet he had that fortitude
to to suffer and to die another point
from shakespeare it's fascinating to me
the more you study these tragedies what
happens is that some tyranny is
unfolding
in a play some tragic um
plot moment and shakespeare will often
show us characters all
standing almost in a ring around the
action
not stepping forward not intervening not
speaking not opening their mouth
that's why when king lear comes in with
his daughter's body in his arms
which is one of the most famous and
bleak moments in shakespearean tragedy
he says murderers traitors cowards all
right exclamation point he's furious and
of course he's crazy
too but he's furious a very
shakespearean moment
were there moments when this could have
been stopped
were there little moments when tyranny
could have been checked
through a small act of fortitude we
often think of the large acts of
fortitude or bravery
but moore's life was a sort of forging
on this point little acts of fortitude
little acts of courage
creating that habit
it's amazing sometimes my students don't
believe me that only a handful of souls
actually opposed henry
it's mind-boggling to think of an entire
country
silent
or playing along with maybe they thought
things would change
who knows um but
never abandon the ship in a storm
the other great lesson from
shakespearean tragedy is
his version of this don't leave the play
early he loves to show this
characters the drama intensifying
becoming more urgent becoming more
well maybe involving wounds or pain or
suffering
and the characters will say things like
i gotta get out of here
or i need to leave now
exit exit exit i need to get off the
present stage
i don't like it here this is going to
hurt
and i've thought you know teaching
shakespeare for 10 years with my
students
the commandment one of them of
shakespearean drama is most certainly
thou shalt not leave early
exclamation quite seriously
never abandon the ship in the storm now
when he gets to the tower of london he
invokes the same image of a
ship's captain again and says it would
be the immortal
infamy of a captain to abandon his ship
under such circumstances
we don't want to overlook again how he
became a man
capable of fortitude at the highest
level
again with points of becoming a
statesman this talk
is to direct our attention to this
middle
story this instructive biography entail
what shakespeare would call the
chronicle of day by day
moment by moment decision by decision
act of fortitude by act of fortitude
chances are you will not be in the tower
of london tomorrow morning at 8 am
the headsman will not be it's not it'll
be a different kind of day
i hope so how did he become prepared for
that
and of course you know for this council
as with all the councils
um i know i'm speaking for myself i like
to allow these figures to
to challenge me am i willing to suffer
wounds
endure even death
or do i prefer that say the truth
suffers because of me
at the end of course um maura loved his
family
his country so much so that he was
willing to lose it for their sake
council 10 the last council be of good
shear you can overcome the world
finally the last council in a way it's
related to the first
wit more was among the funniest of souls
which may not have come out entirely in
in some of the councils
only thomas moore you might say could
jest to the executioner who would behead
him
do your work dear sir but spare my beard
for it at least has not been found
guilty of treason
taking care of his beard even
what a jest i mean he was literally just
moments from death
a jest remembered folks who saw this
eyewitnesses well he was either a wise
foolish man
or a foolish wise man he was either
insane
or not
peaceful joyful
this merry wit of course has deep roots
i want to end with this council
certainly thomas moore had an eye for
the ridiculous in human life he
delighted in all kinds of satires
on our common human frailties he
accepted jess
broken on his own head he had
perspective on himself
and on the political stage while not
abandoning the ship
or standing on the sidelines
this habit made him fit for both life
and death
and prepared him and enabled him to play
the part he was called to play
the true foundation of his humor was his
gladness and joy
inwardly his faith and his trust in god
you might say thomas more's immortal
sense of humor was
refined in this key daily habit
personal reflection and prayer
confidence in god's strength as the key
to his own fortitude
this habit not only strengthened his
performance of daily duties
the key to which was his great love but
it also conferred a piece of soul
that made him capable of the ultimate
sacrifice
and of saying at his trial to the men he
had known his entire life and who are
now condemning him to death
may we all make mary together in heaven
among the statesmen of course moore was
no
never alone in this personal practical
operative faith
of course george washington
is an interesting and famous american
example
sir winston churchill at the siege of
gibraltar
asked for the precise words of a
particular prayer
fear not the result for either thy end
will be enviable and majestic
or god shall preserve us upon the waters
what's instructive when you look at
souls like this
is that they were statesmen they were
leaders they were learned
they were also souls of prayer
it was not something that was foreign to
them
in conclusion i hope these councils
given from my study of the man my
friendship with him really provide some
pause or some fresh fire
or at least some sense of how a single
free and educated man became a statesman
the true friend of his country such that
the following would be written about him
centuries later he was a strong and
courageous spirit
who knew how to despise resolutely the
flattery of human respect
and how to resist in accordance with his
duty
the supreme head of his state nor could
the tears of his wife or the tears of
his children
make him swerve or turn aside from the
path of virtue
then of course there is the man for all
seasons
when meg is asking and begging him to
come out of that tower cell
look now meg if we lived in a state
where virtue was profitable common sense
would make us good and greed would make
us saintly
we live like animals or angels in the
happy land
that never needs heroes
but since in fact we see that avarice
anger envy pride sloth lust and
stupidity commonly profit beyond
humility
chastity fortitude justice and thought
we have to choose to be human at all
why then perhaps meg we must stand
fast a little even at the risk
of being heroes the last council of
thomas more
thank you very much
thank you
thanks we have time now for a few
questions
please wait until the mic comes to you
and raise your hand
if you would like to ask one
sure go ahead you have to wait for the
kitty over here the gentleman in the
blazer
uh did you have any major objections
a man for all season you found
uh incorrect or sure good question
it's it's a brilliant movie and i think
quite truthful to more in fact
the more you think about stories and how
difficult it really is to write a story
well the more you admire robert bolt's
gift for this it's really quite hard to
do
write a play like he wrote the only
objection that comes up for me
personally
in in the play it's just a point of
emphasis
the speech when thomas more says it's
what i believe it's about myself
you know he he speaks in this way about
the self
um and you know to me that moment it's
the only moment really in the play where
i think well
that sounds a lot a little bit more like
robert bolt speaking
um but other than that a very powerful
image of
um thomas moore's life and tremendously
effective
i certainly could have shared lines from
that even line after line from that from
that great film and play
but i think a moving and beautiful
film and play but against the point that
the speech where
moore speaks about his motives
and he says because i believe my own
self
and it just it center rings false like a
false
note to my ears i think he's making a
serious point
that it's personal
i'm responsible for my soul but he puts
it in the language of self and
again i just kind of hear a false note
there
when i when i hear that part of the
movie but good movie
sure
thank you for your words i i too am a
teacher
and uh honestly inspired um
many see in in moore's final resistance
uh and ultimately martyrdom sort of an
image of
um shall we say like the the
the destiny of a clash between
the world and the church and
and despair when they see the ends of
each
in and uh such we'll see such a
disparity between the two
and um and and worry
that you know the fate of of the
virtuous and
and those who love the who love christ
church
will be as sort of a backwater or a
vanguard
against something that is you know
perpetually
doesn't share the same ends um
i'm trying to think of how to make this
a good question without
talking any longer um
did moore really see that that the the
ends of each
city if you will uh were inimical to one
another or i mean what did he have a lot
of hope about
hope for that you know harmony between
the two
yeah he thought that each um the church
and state each had their their proper
office and proper
ends that they served in fact you know
the objection
or one of the objections at the end is
the head of the temporal order
making himself the head of the spiritual
order
more you know most certainly affirmed
the good the goodness of the temporal
order
and and the goodness of of the spiritual
order in fact one of the reasons i kept
coming back to the point about
uh his career is that moore's public
career
is extraordinary testimony to the
goodness of
of a normal professional life
he was he was a worker in london
he was a family man in a way he lived
that that
normal life um and
he served as a lawyer a judge
and those were all duties that he
understood
as as good and fit and proper for the
temporal order
to execute so in his case
um you know i think you get an
affirmation of both
spiritual authority and temporal
authority spiritual good and temporal
good
and i think it is an error to set them
at odds with one another you know that
political life is willy-nilly opposed to
spiritual principles or spiritual life i
think his life suggests otherwise even
though he died
of course the other thing is that from
the beginning of his life
a friendship with henry until the end he
knew that henry had tyrannical leanings
and he was concerned about that from the
beginning of their relationship
and henry was a splendid man in a lot of
ways i mean
he was kind of like he's described like
a god coming down to earth
immense virile uh powerful
virtuous erasmus wrote i mean this guy
could be the
you know he could usher in a new golden
age for christendom i mean it's kind of
this kind of language
and yet there were concerns um about his
character
and moore knew him very very well so
what do you do when
um the head of the temporal order is
tyrannical
i wouldn't throw the temporal order out
i would hope for a change
at the top but in any case it's a good
question
very important question sure davey
oh sure we're good oh hold on joel
give it to mrs
kind of a follow-up on the first
question when you criticize the movie as
uh in the part where they had more
talking in the eye
the second council you gave might have
provided the rationale for the
playwright to do that because as you
said
cicero dictated that to find truth you
look within
in other words that could yes
example yeah certainly and i i think um
as i mentioned
it's uh it's a defensible speech
viewed with that knowledge but to my
ears it sounds a little bit like
um you know kind of 20th century
language of
self that was my only only point uh yeah
cicero said he's very graphic about this
in
the republic he said the statesman or
the leader's first
duty is to examine himself
and to provide as in a mirror an example
to other citizens of this art
the first duty the first duty of a
leader
is to examine himself
and to provide an example of this for
for the people
so certainly you can you can make good
sense of
of bolt but i still think the language
of self leaves me a little cool
um the questions sure
right here in front
i i have to confess that the last time i
asked a question
of a professor was a to contrast
infinitesimal
with infant or finance but i'm not going
to go there
instead i'd i'd like to ask you to to
share some of your thoughts
in a little more detail on uh moore's
use of satire in the
in his writing of another utopia thank
you
uh more admired in particular he
he was a comical satirical genius
and that was his sort of gift as a
writer
and so he admired for example lucian the
ancient
author who was one of the great
satirists of the of the ancient world
and he in particular liked delusion
because he said lucian knew how to
reveal our common frailties
to to hit them to score hits on them
to poke at them in a healthful way
and in such a way that folks didn't
resent being poked at
so that was lucian's gift so he was a
satirist
yes but a kind of a healthful one
must have put it um but this was his
main end
he loved this kind of art
in fact in the friendship and flattery
essay that i mentioned
one of the parts that moore found most
valuable was plutarch's council
on candor he said you know friends need
actually art to help one another
and candor is a kind of artful speech so
he always
admired satire
especially a wit that can reveal the
truth
and move the soul but in such a way that
the soul doesn't resent it
and i think or think it an injury
entirely if you think of our
contemporary satirists i'm not sure this
is entirely their gift
satire's tendency or weakness is to be
just simply destructive
or or to descend into mockery pure and
simple
whereas again for more it was a
revealing
of the ridiculous a revealing of
the common frailties of life but in a
healthful way in such a way that
again folks never resent the author for
his injuries
now moore's most famous satire of course
is utopia
which at the beginning of that work he
says you know some men
don't like satire they're as allergic to
it
as a hydrophobic dog is to water
it's kind of wet he had but in that work
you know in this kind of sunny high
spirited work before he entered henry's
service
moore is gently satirizing intellectuals
and humanists the first audience of the
utopia is moore's fellow intellectuals
and and one contemporary has suggested
that his his portrait of raphael hitler
day the man who
advocates for the utopian order that
raphael is an intellectual
who proves to be something like the
first ideological tyrant in the west
thinking i know better than the
traditions of law
in my native language i can arrange the
social order better
i can make this more just
if you just take away everyone's liberty
it'll work great
he's very excited he's got this great
idea you know and more
is is satirizing
this kind of tyrannical intelligence
and what makes it winning i think is he
he had sympathy for it
he understood you know hey you know
folks who
want to improve things
or who want greater justice in the
temporal order
i think what about this what about that
why is that law in place why don't we
just throw all laws out and start all
over again
and that work takes us as a target for
its satire
this kind of mind and
it does so with with immortal results i
mentioned the uh
contemporary radio personality
um you know thomas more's utopia is not
a work that advocates
socialism this is a misunderstanding of
the book
one that you can you can disprove pretty
handily so after raphael finishes
speaking
describing how great utopia is thomas
moore writes
after i heard raphael out
i thought to myself quite absurd
i don't know again how people missed
that in that sentence he said
that was ridiculous it was interesting
but ridiculous
right um and yet he said you know i
could tell that raphael was tired out
from all his talking
and an ironic moment uh tired out from
all his talking
uh and that he couldn't really bear a
contradiction
so moore said i decided to take him to
dinner instead
and then have a follow-up conversation a
little bit later on
instead of the work has his spirit which
is satirical
and winning and gentle but you can also
see in that last detail
that point on friendship moore wasn't
going to leave
this guy raphael the utopian alone
he wasn't going to abandon him in fact
he was going to have a meal with him
and actually try to ask him some
follow-up questions
the problem with raphael is when you ask
him follow-up questions he answers in a
400 word sentence
and then you ask another question he
gives you a 900 word sentence
and then you ask a third question he
gives you a 40 page monologue
the war's like i'm going to try but
he's just tired right so
he was a satirical genius now that
temperament has its liabilities too
some people think you know if you meet a
satirical person oh they don't take
anything
seriously it's all a jest it's all a
joke
his detractors at the time called him
master mock
they said you could never tell if he was
being serious or not
right that type of that type of person
but one of the one of the other
instructive lessons from his life i
suppose
is that he he knew full well that
that gift of humor that gift of satire
could get him into hot water
um and he and you know he worked to
moderate it
in a letter to one of his kids he said
you know i really like the letter
you wrote me because you make fun of me
very artfully
and yet with fitting moderation
this is just not everyone experiences
and so
that was how you looked at it you know
he you know he knew himself
um and i think because of that uh could
could elite himself
and and eventually others so we all uh
any other questions this will be our
last question for the evening
sure
uh dr smith i was just hoping you would
share with us
uh what made you love thomas moore in
the first place
i was quite serious thank you i was
quite serious about standing in the cell
but to me that was actually the the most
uh moving moment
because it really it became real i had
studied the question
and studied the case almost almost
abstractly
and when i stood in the cell i thought
this really happened
all right hold on a second you know it
was 14 months spent here
you know it became real in a
particularly challenging way and i
always loved the utopia because i
actually do love satire myself
and i enjoyed the wit of thomas moore
immensely but it was that kind of
fundamental wonder
you know how did a man play a part like
this
unto death and that was the beginning of
the serious
uh study of it you know and i had a
wonderful wonderful i should add
wonderful great teacher
and i owe to him a profound debt of
friendship
for for many many things so
combination the cell the teacher study
time admiration
a recipe like that so any case
thank you all and i hope you subscribe
thank you very much uh steve that was
tremendous
uh it was really something to behold
these 65 or so
uh congressional staffers when professor
smith started talking about the
difference between
flattery and friendship uh it
uh evoked particular interest and it was
a
a great pleasure uh uh to uh to hear
this talk and and to know that uh
uh in addition to this there would be so
many other topics on which uh professor
smith
could uh could speak in fact i think
what we'd like to do is tomorrow have an
all-day seminar on dante
now we do look forward to uh to your
returning even and
and uh uh from all of us who have
learned much from you thank you very
much for
uh for uh for your words of wisdom this
evening
i want to make just one quick
announcement and then there are food and
refreshments uh awaiting uh
us all the next talk that we'll have
here is part of our kirby center lecture
series it will be
held on july the 12th
12 30 pm we're going to hear from
stephen hayward
of the american enterprise institute and
he's going to connect up some things
between
his study of the environment in
particular the environmental protection
agency some interesting court cases
and ask the question about the epa
whether there is anything connected to
the protection of private
property in what it does
for those of you who are not
participants in
the washington hillsdale internship
program i know there are many of
you students here we're looking forward
to a great summer
of various excursions including
gettysburg on
the 16th of this month we'll have some
other speakers and other things that
will come up i know
many of you have had a chance to study
with professor tom connor
he's going to be speaking in a
continuing part of this
fusco lecture series so more on that
later this summer
thank you very much all for coming